you guys I can't believe it but III is
here 8:30 2019 the first place that
we're stopping here on the e3 week is
the Xbox briefing so this is the Xbox
press conference I don't know what they
are gonna now I have my fingers crossed
for a new Xbox I've got my ever bought a
I've got my sister Jenna are you excited
I'm so excited you ready to go in I am
okay so let's go in yeah it's hot it is
so hot out here
Nikki hot today Amy see me Hey look at
that same thing last year do you think
you'll cry this year I hope so it's a
gap thing if I cried and cried last year
let's cut back to ed crying Joe
[Music]
[Applause]
this exact money
the moment we get to share the best of
our art form
here with you in LA and the moment you
get to experience breathtaking new
stories new worlds and new heroes for
the Berrier style
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna try I think I'm
so I
instead of the metropolis of the future
where body modification has become an
obsession he plays an outlaw and
enhanced mercenary working with a sleazy
underbelly of Encino when there's the
release
[Applause]
you
Oh
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
right
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm pre-ordering right now
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm so much it's real
oh my god into the Lego McCleary
[Applause]
[Music]
so let's talk about our next month oh
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
it all comes along
this
before my console would never design we
launched Xbox 80 years ago with the game
reviewers called the definitive reason
to own an Xbox because humanity was and
is worth saving next holiday we will
launch project Scarlett with Halo
[Applause]
[Music]
so it's over projects garland looks
incredible halo imminent launch in 2020
holiday okay
why just like the mobile order for
Starbucks so we're gonna go get
Starbucks
Milt's time and then we're gonna be
going into the xbox showcase and I am
hoping fingers crossed that they have
lego Forza I couldn't believe it I
freaked out so our order is here we
ordered so much stuff okay we've got
mine
[Music]
this one and then we have two more wait
no this one's yours Tyler are you
kidding me
make sure there's no sweetener in it so
we accidentally ordered to tell Jenna
how many did you order I ordered two
okay so now we have five I'm embarrassed
look who we ran into at Starbucks it's
aired we just finished the Xbox press
comp it was so good oh thank you
what was your highlight a lot there's a
lot I would say the most Xbox in studio
games ever shown yeah and then of course
I think Gears five and that was our big
section we set the stage on fire
we go to hive on the ground you feel
three wrestlers underneath Lego Forza
okay I don't think Jana Reeves the
carrying on stage that is amazing all
the Lego games I love Lego obviously
halo infinite oh and then the new
next-gen Xbox I'm so excited
we'll be playing it so stay tuned guys
survive e3 oh my god a star like like
this makes me so happy I mean at a video
game convention leaving the Xbox
conference with six coffees so I've
always placed an order at the end of the
Xbox press phone and then I go and
everything's ready when Adam came out on
stage I almost fell off of my freaking
chair look it was such a surprise I
can't believe that didn't leak I don't
that was so cool so good it cypherpunk
was like one of the main things last
year but the fact that we got that
trailer which is just phenomenal and
then O'Connor he just walks out it was
so great it was amazing oh I'm still
shocked I don't know what do you want a
coffee because I bought too many
actually I'm well into my video okay
okay I'm sorry I crashed your video bye
so we just left the press conference
here at Xbox what was your favorite
thing or least favorite thing whatever
you want to go favorite thing is
obviously peanu coming out like you just
can't there's no comparison to that and
then obviously halo yeah it's so great
it always like oh I'm not going to see
something like that you see halo is you
back in ok ok let's go in there inside
the Xbox showcase now and this is what
we actually get hands-on with things I'm
not sure what's gonna be in there but
I'm hoping the Lego force that's gonna
be there because oh my gosh that game is
gonna be so fun but it's actually you're
gonna be out in like a few days so
either way I'm gonna play it well let's
go inside I've got my little capture
hard drive here so we can capture some
gameplay they also have the new Xbox
elite controller this is the second
version and I freaking love this
controller so much let's go look at it
[Applause]
[Music]
just got a chance to see the in Rio Xbox
elite controller and now we're gonna
head in to play some games they told me
that's Lego for toys in here
everyone's like halo halo yes I'm
excited about halo but come on
oh my god it's beautiful it is
absolutely beautiful
I think I'm gonna get it I'm gonna get
it I'm getting in line I'm getting in
line really it's got a place I want to
have this line to play the line
go away I'm so hyped please will I see
Wester I see a world made of grace no no
listen
and that be dinosaurs and then pirate
ship ghost I guess will the city and
cops just
the real thing
like oh do it
in fine
that was so much that was the most fun
this is honestly a dream that I didn't
even know that I wanted to come true
there's a press Start button up here
that'll turn on the engine for you
really step on the gas you hear it okay
look it's Sam Shepard PC boy you ever
played a halo in messenger I actually
have not it's not that easy maybe just
not that good no it's okay I don't want
okay all right all right
okay all right am i playing against real
people it's it's a ten minute demo so
this will expire then you can start over
tonight I already just go in there
exploded also shift rod
[Music]
we're just leaving the showcase I got a
chance to play the Lego force' gate and
get in the McLaren Lego car I was a
little worried about you getting in that
so what was your favorite thing that you
saw the press conference besides Keanu
Reeves coming out on stage and
announcing you know cyberpunk mine I'd
have to say that gears it looks really
really incredible project scarlet halo
I'm excited about that and I look
forward to more fun stuff for me three
so with that I'll see you guys later
go check out his channel and that's it
y'all have a good day
[Music]